thank you I don't know about anyone else
but I really feel it's a privilege to be
here tonight and I'm going to try my
best to but catch a key you sold my
script
no I thought I watch the movie you stole
my strip all that was me I'm their power
you can put me off loser
show me what you can really do you
juggle my chicken run until my real name
does you know so kids to love it
[Applause]
[Applause]
I just gotta say one thing I may not win
anything here tonight in the form of an
Oscar but I really feel it's an amazing
privilege to be standing next to a 100%
certified legend and it's something I
want to treasure for the rest of my life
unbelievable thank you very very much
[Applause]
the actress is nominated for a
performance at a supporting role our
Jane Alexander and all the President's
Men Jodie Foster and taxi driver
Lee grant and voyage of the Damned
pay for Laurie and Carrie
[Applause]
and features straight and network and
the winner is
[Applause]
the one is Beatrice straight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's very heavy and I'm the Dark Horse
and thank you so much all of you it's a
great great thrill for me and very
unexpected though I should have known
that when I had someone like paddy
Chayefsky writing and saying things that
we all feel but can't express and when
we have someone like Sidney Lumet who
makes one want to act forever and a
producer like Howard Godfried then how
can I miss but I know that my mother
would be delighted she had great
potential for an actress but didn't
think she should do it so she pushed me
and was delighted and Michael Chekhov
the great actor and teacher who I
studied with who gave me a love and
respect for the theater which is the
whole point of why we're all here it's a
great profession and we have to keep
thinking it all the time and we all do
and we all love it and I'm so grateful
for that and for a wonderful lady age 93
who lives here in Los Angeles
who's watching tonight one of our first
women directors who directed Paul
Robeson in Othello in London Ellen Van
Valkenburg Brown bright as ever
thank you and last but not least my
husband who is put up with me for 28
years thank you so so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]